rescue teams scramble to reach
passengers
trapped in the front carriages carriages
that folded into each other
after coming off the rails as the train
entered a tunnel this woman yells
carriage 4 carriage 4
has everyone come out 350 passengers
paid for seats
with more than 100 others reportedly
standing
i could feel the emergency brake was put
on and the train just shook
and then it stopped
we're fine but some of the passengers in
our compartment were injured
inside the narrow tunnel emergency
workers struggled to reach the injury
there was no other way for us to get out
so we had to climb to the top of the
train and then climb down
i was sitting on the isle side and i was
thrown to the floor
a spokesman for the rail network says
the accident was caused
by one of its construction trucks
sliding from a work site
above the track the fire department
later released pictures of what appeared
to be the wreckage
of the truck beside the derailed train
this is taiwan's worst ever train
accident and it's believed many of the
dead
and injured were heading home to mark
the four-day
annual ching-ming holiday when chinese
people
tend family graves adrian brown al
jazeera hong kong